die fallzahlen befinden sich ja seit
wochen auf einem hohen plateau aktuell
sehen wir sogar wieder einen anstieg der
fallzahlen und dass man da und herren
ist tatsächlich besorgniserregend für
gestern wurden uns um 23.000 679 neue
fälle übermittelt das ist ein trauriger
bisheriger rückstand innerhalb eines
tages immer noch infizieren sich zu
viele menschen mit saas koch 2 die
folgen hatte ich schon in den letzten
presse briefings beschrieben die
gesundheitsämter sind zunehmend
erschöpft
in einigen regionen haben krankenhäuser
ihre belastungsgrenze erreicht wir sehen
immer mehr ausbrüche in alten und
pflegeheimen und die zahl der schweren
verläufe und auch todesfälle nimmt immer
weiter zu
und wir wissen das ist auch bei
patienten die kogit 19 gut überstehen zu
langzeit folgen kommen kann
auch diese fälle meine damen und herren
werden natürlich leider weiter zunehmen
hinzu kommt dass dieses plateau auf dem
wir uns befinden äußerst fragil ist das
zeigen unsere modellierungen das
infektionsgeschehen kann schnell wieder
kippen
die fallzahlen können rasch wieder
exponentiell ansteigen
dafür reichen wenige zusätzliche fälle
aus und man darunter das müssen wir
verhindern
das virus ist in bevölkerung weit
verbreitet wir nennen dies ein diffuses
geschehen in der bevölkerung wir sehen
aber auch dass es in deutschland große
regionale unterschiede gibt
in manchen regionen gelingt es offenbar
besser infektionen zu verhindern
als in anderen was zeigt uns dass das
zeigt dass infektionsschutz maßnahmen
wirken wenn sie effektiv umgesetzt
werden
das wissen wir übrigens auch aus anderen
ländern außerhalb von deutschland
das heißt infektion könne verhindert
werden
das gelingt aber nur wenn wir alle
konsequent mitmachen wenn wir alle
die aha + l regeln einhalte
und wenn wir alle unsere kontakte auf
das zwingend notwendige reduzieren meine
kollegen dr
rexroth wird ihnen die aktuellen
fallzahlen im detail vorstellen
sie ist infektionsepidemiologie und
leitet unser lagezentrum am
robert-koch-institut ja also seit beginn
der pandemie bis heute also dem 10 12 22
00 uhr wo dem rk ii insgesamt eine
million 242 1271 19 fälle übermittelt
wir schätzen dass bis heute etwa 2 900
22.100 menschen die akute infektion
überstanden haben
aber sie haben es gerade schon gehört ja
über 20.000 20.000 372 menschen sind an
oder mit dieser infektion verstorben
die fallzahlen sind insgesamt weiterhin
auf einem sehr hohen niveau
im november wurden uns täglich zwischen
11.000 23.000 fans rk übermittelt und
heute herr villa hat schon gesagt wenn
wir ein tageshöchstwert mit 23.600 79
fällen seit einigen tagen beraten wir
leider auch wieder ein anstieg der
fallzahlen in der letzten woche haben
wir beispielsweise donnerstags an dieser
stelle 22.000 fälle berichtet und heute
ungefähr 222.000 und heute sind es eben
wie gesagt über 23.000 neue fälle der
sieben tage eher wert der schwante auch
die ganze zeit um 1 schon seit wochen
und die bundesweite 7 tages incidents
ist ebenfalls weiter angestiegen und
liegt inzwischen bei fast 150 also 149
fälle je 100.000 einwohner
die entwicklung unterscheidet sich nach
wie vor nach bundesland wenn sie bitte
die grafik 1 1 trennten haben wir auch
in unserem situationsbericht und die
vergangenen wochen schon gezeigt die
zeit nach jeweiligen berichts datum über
den letzten
monat die sieben tage sind sie denn der
bundesländer und dort sehen sie das in
vielen bundesländern dieser wert auf
einem hohen niveau stabil bleibt
wir sehen dass bayern auch
baden-württemberg zum beispiel auf einem
hohen niveau stabil sind es gibt leichte
rückgänge in nrw und niedersachsen
aber ja auch in berlin und bremen zum
beispiel nimmt die sieben tage sind sie
denn tendenziell leicht ab allerdings
mit schwankungen und besorgniserregend
dass eben die entwicklung zb
sachsen-anhalt brandenburg vor allem
aber thüringen und sachsen wo in den
letzten wochen in der letzten woche auch
weiter noch zu eine zunahme zu
betrachten ist
auf kommunaler ebene gibt es dann auch
noch deutliche unterschiede wir haben ja
über 400 stadt und landkreise bzw
kreisfreie städte in deutschland und
wenn sie bitte die grafik 2 1 blenden
würden die iss aus unserem dashboard das
können sie sich also auch online
jederzeit anschauen
dort sehen sie diese entwicklung die
sieben tages inzidenz auch nach
landkreisen und dort können sie eben
sehen dass das bild auch recht heterogen
als die meisten landkreise also 264 die
haben derzeit eine 7 tages incidence
zwischen 100 und 250 400.000 einwohner
sind also rot gefärbt es gibt 85
landkreise die eine 7 tag sind sie denn
von weniger 124 weniger als 50 sie ein
grenzwert ist heute gibt es auch zwei
landkreise die sogar mehr als 500
400.000 einwohner in den letzten sieben
tagen getestet positiv getestet haben
in einigen landkreisen ist der trend
auch rückläufig und das zeigt uns dass
die fallzahlen durchaus in schach
gehalten werden könne wenn die
empfohlenen maßnahmen ein
gehalten und umgesetzt werden die
fallzahlen unterscheiden sich nach wie
vor nicht nur regional sondern auch nach
altersgruppen und da haben wir in den
letzten wochen häufiger eine abbildung
gezeigt die finden sie auch in unserem
lagebericht wir sehen in den letzten
wochen dass vor allem die jüngeren
aktionen betroffen waren also die 15 bis
59 jährigen waren recht stark betroffen
darunter wieder die 15 bis 34 jährigen
ab stärken also die jüngeren erwachsenen
dort liegen die sieben tages residenzen
derzeit bei 184 400.000 einwohner der
rückgang
wir hatten ja ein rückgang betrachtet in
dieser altersgruppe in den letzten
wochen der hat sich leider ein bisschen
gebremst wieder gebremst abgebremst und
leider sehen wir auch weiterhin immer
mehr ältere menschen
das macht uns natürlich besonders sorge
wenn besonders viele menschen über 80
jahre betroffen sind weil die ja
besonders gefährdet sind auch für
schwerere verläufe den süden sind dieser
altersgruppe also bei den über
80-jährigen die liegt schon bei fast 250
g 100000 einwohner 248 400.000 hatten
wir zuletzt und das steigt auch weiter
leider deutlich an
also wir sehen auch leider immer noch
sehr viele ausbrüchen alten und
pflegeheim wir sehen tatsächlich sogar
fast doppelt so viele ausbrüche in
alten- und pflegeheim wie im frühjahr
und es sind auch pro ausbruch sehr viele
menschen betroffen sogar im durchschnitt
fast 20 die anzahl der patienten
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden
müssen die steigt entsprechend auch
immer weiter an und hat mit stand
gestern 4278 erreicht diese daten
bekommen wir vom tv intensiv register
ja und das also diese zahlen die zeigen
uns eben dass wir noch weiter betonen
können dass das virus einfach in der
bevölkerung zirkuliert in der gesamten
bevölkerung und eben auch zunehmend in
den risikogruppen und das führt wie wir
jetzt in den
wovon er leider deutlich sehen mussten
dazu dass es immer mehr schwere verläufe
und auch todesfälle gibt und die
schweren verläufe und die todesfälle die
brauchen immer eine zeit dass wir die in
den daten sehen das heißt wir müssen
damit rechnen dass in den nächsten tagen
und wochen auch noch deutlich mehr fälle
dazukommen
und daher ist es wirklich absolut
wichtig dass die inzidenz in allen
bundesländern und auch in allen
altersgruppen fällt denn neuinfektionen
müssen überall so gut wie möglich
verhindert werden damit das auch gelingt
diese gefährdeten gruppen zu schützen
aktuell zirkuliert das virus in der
bevölkerung und es ist nicht mehr so wie
am anfang der pandemie oder auch im
sommer dass wir einzelne
ausbruchsgeschehen hatten sondern es ist
wirklich ein diffuses geschehen und die
eindämmung dessen gelingt eben wirklich
nur wenn die gesamte bevölkerung dieser
maßnahmen mitträgt und diese kontakt
reduktion wirklich konsequent umsetzt
danke für exot
ich möchte noch ein paar ergänzungen
anführen neben den meldedaten beziehen
wir nämlich auch noch viele weitere
daten ein um das infektionsgeschehen mit
saas kopf zu in deutschland besser
beschreiben zu können und analysieren zu
können
ich möchte dass an dieser stelle
nochmals erläutern wir haben eben robert
koch-institut viele also mehrere
etablierte serversysteme für akute
atemwegserkrankungen und wir nutzen
diese auch schon seit jahren zur
überwachung zum beispiel der jährlichen
grippewelle und wir haben auch noch
weitere sowie jens tools die ich kurz
ansprüche wir haben unsere systeme
kontinuierlich weiterentwickelt und
deshalb helfen sie uns auch jetzt die
kurve 19 pandemie zu erfassen und
einzuschätzen da gibt es zum beispiel
rund 750 arztpraxen in ganz deutschland
die uns wöchentlich berichten wie viele
menschen mit akuten atemwegserkrankungen
zu ihnen kommen einige davon das sind
circa 100 arztpraxen schicken uns auch
proben die wir auch verschiedene viren
die atemwegserkrankungen hervorrufen
untersuchen zum beispiel auf grippe
viren auf verschiedene andere erkältungs
führen und seit februar diesen jahres
auch auf
koch 2 außerdem haben wir das projekt
grippewelle da berichten uns mehr als
9000 bürger online jede woche ob sie
einer akuten atemwegsinfektion hatten
und wenn ja welche symptome sie hatten
bei grippe web kann jeder mitmachen und
damit die datenbasis weiter stärken
jeder kann sich registrieren unter
grippe web.de einige teilnehmer haben
von uns auch testkits zugeschickt
bekommen so dass sie beim auftreten von
symptomen selbst proben entnehmen können
und dann diese uns zuschicken können
diese proben werden ebenfalls auf
atemwegs viren untersucht natürlich auch
wieder
ebenfalls inklusive saß kopf zwei wir
uns natürlich auch die information aus
der korona daten spender app die wir für
uns wie ein fieberthermometer betrachten
wir fahren auch über das die wii
register wie viele mitmenschen wegen
cupid 19 aktuell auf intensivstationen
behandelt werden und meine damen und
herren wir haben auch eine krankenhaus
syriens eine gruppe von aktuell 73
krankenhäusern berichten uns regelmäßig
über patienten die wegen
atemwegsinfektion stationär behandelt
werden müssen also im krankenhaus
behandelt werden und diese informationen
zusammengefasst sind sehr wichtig zur
einschätzung wie schwer die erkrankungen
verlaufen und ob die patienten auf der
intensivstation zum beispiel behandelt
werden müssen oder eben nicht
diese daten aus den verschiedenen
systemen geben uns ein gesamtbild über
die situation und wie sich diese aktuell
entwickelt zusätzlich zu den meldezahlen
die uns vom exoten vorgestellt hat und
zwar sowohl von kuwait 19 erkrankung als
auch von anderen atemwegserkrankungen
wir veröffentlichen diese ergebnisse
deshalb unter anderem jeden donnerstag
in unserem situationsbericht meine damen
was sagen diese systeme und warum sind
sie so wichtig aktuell leiden nach
diesen daten etwa drei von 100 menschen
in deutschland an einer akuten
atemwegserkrankungen das sind übrigens
im vergleich zu den vorjahren weniger
und auch an grippeähnlichen erkrankungen
also mit fieber leiden gerade weniger
menschen als das in den vorjahren der
fall war
das heißt dass sich aufgrund der kontakt
beschränkungen und dem einhalten der a+a
regeln insgesamt weniger menschen mit
diesen atemwegserkrankung erregern
infizieren die maßnahmen wirken also wir
sehen dass wir durch diese maßnahmen
erkrankungen verhindern grippe andere
atemwegserkrankungen aber eben auch mit
19 uhr wird 19 aber und das ist ein
entscheidender unterschied ist aufgrund
der geringen e mobilität in der
bevölkerung und aufgrund der tatsache
dass die übertragung schon vor
krankheitsbeginn stattfindet am
schwersten zu reduzieren diese fälle
sind am schwersten zu reduzieren und wir
sehen in der krankenhaus so war es auch
dass mehr als die hälfte der fälle die
momentan wegen akuter
atemwegserkrankungen behandelt werden
auf cupid 19 zurückzuführen sind und
dies eben auch bei den altersgruppen
unter 65 also nicht nur bei den
hochhaltigen was wiederum ein beleg ist
für das diffuse auftreten der krankheit
in deutschland
es gibt auch fragen die wir nicht mit
diesen meldedaten beantworten können
oder mit hilfe der serversysteme und
eine ganz entscheidende frage die immer
wieder gestellt wird ist die wie viele
menschen in deutschland waren eigentlich
bereits mit saas kopf zu infiziert ohne
dies zu wissen und wie viele fälle
werden nicht erfasst bleiben also
unerkannt das ist die so genannte
dunkelziffer und diese frage ist unter
anderem deshalb so wichtig weil man mit
der antwort die künftige verbreitung des
virus natürlich besser einschätzen kann
das ermöglicht es uns zielgerichtet und
mit passenden maßnahmen umzugehen
um diese frage zu beantworten reicht es
also nicht ausschließlich zu erfassen
wie viele menschen bis jetzt mit einer
pcr oder einem schnelltest positiv
getestet worden
denn es werden eben nicht alle unbedingt
getestet die sich angesteckt haben
einige merken aufgrund ihrer vielen
symptome auch gar nicht dass sie sich
angesteckt haben
oder sie werden nicht im richtigen
zeitfenster getestet
und um den anteil der menschen in
deutschland bereits infiziert waren
möglichst genau zu schätzen
führen wir deshalb seit einigen monaten
studien durch in diesen studien testen
wir blutproben auf antikörper gegen das
saas kopf fallen auf unserer website
können sie detaillierte informationen zu
den vergangenen und laufenden studien
übrigens finden und zwar unter der
rubrik forschung auf der website die
sich mit cupid 19 befasst nun meine
damen und herren wie funktionieren diese
blutproben die so genannten zero
epidemiologischen studien in diesen
studien werden verschiedene arten von
blutproben untersucht zb blutproben von
blutspenden oder stichproben aus der
breiteren bevölkerung in münchen gibt es
bereits eine repräsentative stichprobe
die also die dortige bevölkerung gut
abbildet und den anteil bereits
infizierte besonders gut schätzen kann
es gibt auch gezielte studien aus
sogenannten hot spots also aus
definierten orten bzw gebieten in denen
innerhalb eines kurzen zeitraums
besonders viele menschen infiziert
wurden besonders große aufbrüche
ausbrüche gesehen wurden die ergebnisse
dieser studien zeigen dass ich im
frühjahr und sommer
in einigen dieser hot spots bis zu 15
prozent der bewohner angesteckt haben
das heißt dass ich in diesen definierten
orten oder gebieten etwa einer von
sieben bewohnern angesteckt hat in den
meisten gebieten waren ist jedoch bis
dahin viel weniger wir müssen davon
ausgehen dass ich im durchschnitt noch
wenige prozent der bevölkerung aktuell
erst infiziert haben sicherlich ist
dieser bereich noch im einstelligen
prozentbereich
eine übersicht veröffentlicht wie heute
übrigens im epidemiologischen der tat
aber die bereits in deutschland
durchgeführten studie unserer meldedaten
wurde in deutschland bislang rund 1,2
millionen menschen mit dem virus
angesteckt die daten hat ihn volkswirt
gerade vermittelt dies entspricht also
etwa 1,5 oder ein bis zwei menschen von
11 5% oder ein bis zwei menschen von 100
menschen
wir gehen aber natürlich von einer unter
fast
da wir bereits dargelegt nicht alle
getestet werden die sie angesteckt haben
aber die antikörper studien zeigen
bislang für deutschland weniger
untererfassung als das in den meisten
internationalen studien vorliegt
zum schluss noch ein paar bemerkungen
zum impfen zur impfempfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission dieser gruppe
von unabhängigen wissenschaftlern deren
geschäftsstelle am robert koch institut
ist und diese empfehlung wird zurzeit ja
in der presse diskutiert
es handelt sich meine damen und herren
dabei immer noch um einen entwurf das
möchte ich ganz deutlich sagen die
bundesländer und fachgesellschaften
haben nun die gelegenheit diesen entwurf
stellung zu nehmen
danach wird der entwurf wenn nötig
angepasst und erst dann wird er in
finale version vorliegen
wann genau das geschehen wird das weiß
ich nicht aber es wird natürlich in
kürze sein
die empfehlung gilt natürlich
vorbehaltlich der zulassung eines
impfstoffs und mit der zulassung der
ersten stufe wird aber schon ende 2020
anfang 20 21 gerechnet also wirklich
sehr bald ich möchte ein überblick über
die zentralen punkte des entwurfs der
stiko geben wir wählen meine damen und
herren am anfang nicht genügend
impfstoff dosen haben um alle
mitbürgerinnen mitbürger zu impfen daher
sieht der derzeitige entwurf der
empfehlung vor dass zunächst denjenigen
die impfung angeboten werden soll die
ein besonders hohes risiko für schwere
oder tödliche verläufe einer kurve 19
erkrankung haben oder die beruflich ein
besonders hohes ansteckungsrisiko oder
einen engen kontakt zu schutzbedürftigen
personen gruppen haben wenn der
impfstoff zunächst lose begrenzt zur
verfügung steht dann soll laut entwurf
der stiko empfehlung die impfung
zunächst folgenden gruppen angeboten
werden bewohnerinnen von senioren und
altenpflegeheimen personen personen im
alter von über 80 jahren personal mit
besonders hohem exposition risiko im
medizinischen einrichtungen zum beispiel
notaufnahmen in der medizinischen
betreuung von kuwait 19 patienten
personal in medizinischen einrichtung
mit engem kontakt zu wollen haben
gruppen also zum beispiel in der hämato
onkologie oder in der
transplantationsmedizin pflegepersonal
in der ambulanten stationären
altenpflege sowie andere tätigkeiten
tätige in senioren- und altenpflegeheime
mit kontakt zu den bewohnern
bewohnerinnen wenn wir nun die impfung
zunächst menschen ab 80 jahren und
bewohnerinnen von alten- und pflegeheim
anbieten dann können am meisten schwere
erkrankungen und todesfälle verhindert
werden
das haben die modellierungen
verschiedener impfstrategien ergeben es
ist klar
meine damen und herren dass das alter
der wesentlichen risikofaktor für eine
schwere chronische erkrankung ist
wir sehen dass immer mehr ältere
menschen an kuwait 19 betroffen sind die
inzidenz bei den über 80 jährigen liegt
momentan bei 248 pro 100.000 wir sehen
derzeit doppelt so viele ausbrüche in
alten- und pflegeheim dem früher die
zahl infizierten den altenpfleger im
leben oder arbeiten steigt seit mitte
oktober kontinuierlich stark an
und der großteil der todesfälle die wir
leider beklagen müssen nämlich mehr als
13.000 der uns bekannten 20.000 betrifft
menschen die 80 jahre und älter sind
deshalb ist es wichtig gerade die ersten
phasen der nur wenig impfstoff zur
verfügung steht diesen personenkreis
zuerst zu impfen denn wenn die bewohner
in alten- und pflegeheim erst einmal
immun gegen das virus sind dann werden
sehr viele todesfälle verhindert und
dadurch natürlich auch die krankenhäuser
entlastet und die arztpraxen möchte
dieser stelle betonen es handle sich um
einen entwurf der stiko empfehlung wie
diese empfehlung konkret umgesetzt wird
das wird auch davon abhängen wie viel
impfstoff um schlussendlich vorhanden
sein wird und wie die länder das vor ort
dann umsetzen können und ich möchte an
dieser stelle auch noch mal einmal
betonen alle gruppen die in dem entwurf
als priorisierte gruppen genannt werden
werden genannt weil man bei begrenzt
zum impfstoff dosen auf der grundlage
von ethischen prinzipien und
wissenschaftlicher evidenz eine
priorisierung vornehmen muss die
priorisierung letzte ist nicht so zu
verstehen als wären die nicht an
oberster stelle priorisierten gruppen
nicht wichtig voraussichtlich werden wir
im verlauf des nächsten jahres dann mehr
und mehr impfstoff dosen zur verfügung
haben so dass dann nur vorübergehend
gruppen die das höchste risiko für
schwere erkrankungen und tod sowie
expeditionen haben priorisiert werden
müssen mittelfristig wenn doch dann
wollen wir natürlich allen menschen
zugang zum cupid 19 impfstoffen geben
und wir bieten diesen impfstoff an und
wir hoffen natürlich dass das angebot
auch angenommen wird
unser ziel ist es nach wie vor
neuinfektionen so gut wie möglich und
mit aller kraft meine damen und herren
zu verhindern wir müssen verhindern dass
menschen überhaupt erst krank werden und
nur so lässt sich verhindern dass
kontakte in quarantäne müssen dass das
virus zu risikogruppen weitergetragen
wird dass patienten ins krankenhaus oder
sogar auf die intensivstation kommen
dass menschen sterben und dass menschen
langzeitfolgen durch coop 19 erleiden
wir stehen diesem virus nicht machtlos
gegenüber wir haben eine gute strategie
sie besteht seit anfang an aus drei
teilen eindämmung schutz abbildung was
bedeuten diese drei pfeiler im einzelnen
erstens eindämmung der krankheit zur
eindämmung können und müssen wir aber
auch wirklich alle beitragen beherzigen
wir doch alle die asl regeln halten wir
abstand wo immer möglich halten wir die
hygieneregeln tragen wie dort womöglich
alltags masken oder medizinische mund
nasen schutz und dürften wir meine damen
tragen und zwar immer und überall auch
in alltagssituationen ob das seine
privaten oder im beruflichen bereich wo
immer das möglich ist bitte tun wir das
alle konzentrieren wir unsere kontakte
wirklich auf ein minimum treffen wir uns
generell mit zu wenig menschen wie
möglich
das virus verbreitet sich dort wo
menschen zusammen
gerade wenn man sich gut kennt und näher
zusammenrückt natürlich verzichten sie
auf solche treffen bitte schützen sie
sich und ihre familien und ihre freunde
wir alle schützen bitte unsere familien
und unsere freunde und wenn sie symptome
einer akuten atemwegsinfektionen haben
bleiben wir bitte alle fünf tage zu
hause damit wir niemanden anstecken und
natürlich bleibt die arbeit der
gesundheitsämter weiter zentrale
infektionsketten aufspüren und
aufbrechen und dadurch unterbrechen
das zweite element dieser strategie ist
der schutz für besonders gefährdete
gruppen zum beispiel für menschen
altenheim die ein hohes risiko haben an
co mit 19 zu erkranken und zwar schwer
zu erkranken
hier ist es ganz entscheidend dass das
virus eben erst gar nicht in die heime
hineingetragen wird auch dazu können wir
natürlich selber beitragen
und an dieser stelle möchte ich ganz
besonders den vielen pflegekräften
danken die selbst alles dafür tun um
einen eintrag in ihr heim auch zu
verhindern
neben der arbeit die sie in den heimen
leisten sie arbeiten oft unter schweren
bedingungen fiel auch weit weg von der
eigenen familie und sie alle leisten in
der pandemie großartiges bitte machen
sie weiter so helfen sie weiter dabei
ihre bewohner zu schützen und das dritte
element der pandemie
bekämpfungsstrategie ist die milderung
also dass abmildern der folgen dieser
pandemie zb durch neue und bessere
therapieansätze oder durch aufstockung
von kapazitäten im krankenhaus und
natürlich auch meine damen und herren
durch eine impfung die in deutschland
bald verfügbar sein wird
und diese drei elemente eindämmung
schutz und bildung die müssen weiter
aufrecht erhalten werden und jeder von
uns kann an dem platz an dem ihr das
möglich ist dazu beitragen dass diese
strategie erfolgreich bleibt nur
gemeinsam wird es uns gelingen das
infektionsgeschehen auf ein level zu
bringen mit dem wir alle umgehen können
wir können die trendwende nur gemeinsam
schaffen strengen wir uns also alle
gemeinsam
am sonntag ist der dritte advent das
jahr 2020 geht bald zu ende nicht aber
unsere solidarität
gemeinsam zeigen wir diesen virus die
stirn
danke sehr vielen dank
wir gehen zu den fragen und fragen als
erstes den andreas rinke von reuters
guten morgen herr rinke zwei einmal zu
den ergebnissen die sind ja auch egal
wie unterschiedlich man sich die zahlen
für hessen
oktober 2001 oder sehr unterschiedlichen
zahlen erklären die sich eigentlich dass
sehr viel mehr menschen also die
installationszahlen sind dort mehr ein
halbe betroffen
die zweite frage ist und dass wir die
prioritätenliste nun gibt es ein
großbritannien das verhältnis zum
beispiel die der impfstoff der jetzt
schon größer und älter und weiser nicht
angewandt werden sollte
an diese ergebnisse die jetzt aus
großbritannien vor ihren einfluss auf
die priorisierung der krupp wir in
deutschland ja ich würde die impfung
frage als erstmal anderen dann gibt die
zweite frage an frau rexroth weiter wir
beobachten die die daten sind sehr
frisch die daten die wir haben wir haben
wir noch nicht oder was heißt wir also
die die regulatorischen behörden die
kolleginnen und kollegen die sich diese
unterlagen anschauen die ergebnisse der
studien der studien die zu den zulassung
geführt haben die sind ja noch nicht
fertig mit den auswertungen und das was
sie ansprechen sind einzelfälle die
weiter betrachtet werden müssen und das
ist jetzt genau die aufgabe die stiko
unter anderem das paul-ehrlich-institut
als robert koch institut wird sobald die
impfungen dann in deutschland anfangen
kontinuierlich monitoren wie wir das
sagen also beachten betrachten und
analysieren welche nebenwirkungen
auftauchen und diese werden langfristig
überprüft und es kann natürlich sein
dass dann bestimmte änderungen in den
stiko empfehlungen auftauchen das ist so
und das wird auch die nächste zeit zu
bleiben warum ist das jetzt besonders so
der eben stoff oder ein kurzer zeit
entwickelt der beobachtungszeitraum der
menschen die gerade mit dem bei und tag
im stoff geimpft wurden also das sind
hier rund 20.000 der
beobachtungszeitraum ist erst wenige
monate und durch die impfkampagne
durchgeführt werden verlängert sich der
beobachtungszeitraum und dann werden
diese möglichen nebenwirkungen weiter
erfasst und werden natürlich auch
gegebenenfalls einfluss haben auf die
stiko empfehlungen da auch dieses
dokument ist ein lebendes documenta und
zu ihrer ersten frage den anteil der
verstorbenen überhaupt die todeszahlen
ja danke für die frage da können
vielleicht auch noch mal die grafik 3
einblenden die vorhin haben wir die
nicht gezeigt aber die haben wir auch
dabei also das ist sind die verstorbene
nach sterbe woche und sie sehen da
insgesamt dass wir insgesamt in
deutschland über 200.000 todesfälle
hatten und dass das über 20.000
entschuldigung todesfälle und das ist
jetzt auch deutlich mehr noch mal sind
als zu während der ersten phase der
pandemie am dienstag wurden 590
todesfälle übermittelt was wirklich mit
abstand der höchste wert war innerhalb
eines tages und heute herr wille hat das
gesagt sind es ja auch deutlich über 400
und sehr völlig recht dass tatsächlich
diese todesfälle unterschiedlich
regional auch verteilt sind
also da ist es aber vielleicht ein
bisschen besser sich anzugucken wie ist
es auf die inzidenz also auf die
bevölkerung bezogen als die absoluten
todesfalls seien
und dann
natürlich auch auf die altersgruppen
also man sieht da schon regionale
deutliche unterschiede natürlich auch
international aber regional auch und wie
sie sagen sind die südwestdeutschen und
süd ostdeutschen bundesländer eben
stärker betroffen als die nördlichen
bundesländer und das kann
unterschiedliche ursachen haben zum
einen natürlich spiegelt es auf eine
gewisse weise auch die unterschiedliche
demographie wieder wenn man nicht in
jedem bundesland die gleiche alter
zusammensetzung also es gibt etwas
durchschnittlich ältere bevölkerung und
durchschnittlich jüngere bevölkerung zum
anderen spiegelt das sicherlich auch
wieder wie viele ausbrüche in alten und
pflegeheimen
wir sehen das ist auch sehr
unterschiedlich ist ist zum teil
möglicherweise auch durch
unterschiedliche screenings und test
strategien bedingt dass gerade der
anteil dass manchen orten regional
einfach großzügig ihre getestet wird als
in anderen
es hängt auch damit zusammen an welchem
punkt der kurve wir uns aktuell befinden
weil es ja immer eine ganze weile dauert
bis die verstorbene neben in den daten
überhaupt schwer erkranken dem die
patienten erkrankungen versterben und
wir das in den daten sehen das heißt
wenn sie irgendwo auf der aufsteigenden
kurve sind dann ist der anteil der
verstorbenen erst mal geringer und
später wird er dann wieder höher aber
insgesamt sehen wir deutlich sehr sehr
unterschiedliche belastungen gerade eben
im süden südwesten und südosten der
republik zum teil sehr hohe todesfälle
fallzahlen wo auch einzelne landkreise
wirklich sehr viel verstorbene schon zu
beklagen haben
vielen antiken zu dpa frauen schinski
guten morgen was heißt das jetzt
es gibt jede menge maßnahmen werden die
eltern zu wenig folgt und in den
gleichen gaben die meisten kritiken oder
den leuten nach oben sieht anrichten
also sie haben recht mit der annahme
dass die entwicklung nicht so ist wie
ich sie mir erwünscht hat und wie ihr
wahrscheinlich jeder in diesem land sich
sie erwünscht hatte diese zweite frage
die sie gestellt haben kann ich nicht
beantworten dazu sind mir keine
informationen oder daten bekannt woran
liegt es nun es ist folgendes zu
bemerken wir führen ja auch unter der
federführung von cornelia betsch von der
universität in erfurt dieser kosmos
studie durch und in der kosmos studie
merkt man schon sehr stark das natürlich
eine gewisse ermüdung in der bevölkerung
da ist man merkt auch dass teilweise das
risikobewusstsein sich etwas verändert
das heißt es gibt auch offensichtlich
der anteil der menschen die denken ja
die krankheit eigentlich verhalte ich
mich richtig aber sie sie die die
compliance also der die maßnahmen setzen
sie dann doch gar nicht so richtig
umgehe hat sich erhöht in den letzten
wochen und was wir sehen und das ist ein
ganz harter und klarer marca wir sehen
einfach dass die anzahl der kontakt
beschränkungen das können wir relativ
gut messen mit den systemen die ich eben
auch grad teilweise vorgestellt habe und
durch modellierung die wir auch am haus
und auch andere natürlich durchführen
wir sehen dass der anteil der kontakt
reduktion einfach nicht ausreicht
willkommen bislang auf eine kontakt
reduktion auf etwa führt um etwa 40
prozent
und wir sind der festen meinung dass wir
einen kontakt reduktion brauchen die
über 60 prozent liegt
das sehen wir ganz gut in einer grafik
die die ihnen auch wahrscheinlich
bekannt ist die gestern in dem
leopoldina paper auch war sie sehen dass
wir im frühjahr weit über 60 prozent
kontakt redaktion hatten das war ein
erfolgreiches eingreifen und wir sehen
das in anderen ländern irland und
belgien sind da zb oder als als beispiel
genannt dass dort die jetzt sehr
erfolgreich durch ihre maßnahmen die
zahlen runter gebracht haben dass dort
die kontakt reduktion eben über 60%
gegangen ist das hat bei uns nicht
ausgereicht und darum müssen die kontakt
reduktion stärker werden dann ist nach
unserer lesart und nach dem was wirklich
wie mehrheit der wissenschaftlerin
wissenschaftler sagt dann kriegen wir
diese zahlen auch wieder runter also ich
kann mich nur wiederholen
das hängt in hohem maße damit zusammen
wie wir alle uns verhalten wir sind
diese menschen die das virus tragen wir
sind diejenigen die diese reduktion
durch einschränkungen unserer kontakte
aktiv herbeiführen können
vielen dank wir nur ein vater
etwas weggebrochen die frage musste
wiederholt werden weil der schinski
können sie ihre frage noch mal
nachfragen erstellen
er war gerade weg also wenn die menschen
nicht von alleine diese 60 prozent
reduktion schaffen dann dann muss man
sicher andere maßnahmen sich überlegen
ja wenn es nicht gelingt dann sehe ich
keine andere möglichkeit
wir gehen zu henrike roßbach von der
süddeutschen zeitung
ich habe auch die frage auf das
leopoldina papier und die impfstrategie
der stiko im leopoldina papier wird
vorgeschlagen ab weil sie montag die
schulpflicht auszusetzen und die schulen
januar
gleichzeitig sind ja die lehrer in dem
stiko papier in der gruppe 4 und wenn es
um die verbreitung und verhinderung von
infektionen gibt glaube ich so meine
tore 5 das heißt werden offensichtlich
als nicht so stark ist werdet gesehen
worauf man ja den schluss ziehen dass
auch schon jetzt nicht mehr auf sind an
dem es primär zu einem sehr starken
infektionsgeschehen kommen selbst können
sieht man erklären man sieht man ja auch
in der leopoldina gruppe gleichzeitig
ist die iss die die stiko empfehlung die
stiko ihnen eine side
wie kommst du dieser diskrepanz ist also
können sie das einfach mal klar
ja das ist ganz einfach zu erklären wenn
wir heute für jeden bundesbürger eine
impfdosis hätten dann bräuchten wir
natürlich diese priorisierung in diesem
harten maße ton nicht durchzuführen wir
würden die selbe priorisierung haben
weil wir ja risiko und berechnen
modellieren aber wir könnten natürlich
die gruppen viel schneller durchkämpfen
aber trotz aller und das muss man
einfach mal sagen du hast dieses
großartigen erfolg ist dass er so früh
schon den eben stoff haben das haben ja
im frühjahr diesen jahres also kaum
jemand erwartet dass sie ein riesiger
erfolg und ein mehr als als licht am
ende des tunnels trotzdem haben wir
natürlich nicht genügend impfstoff um
die menschen zu impfen
unser ziel ist es ja immer die ganze
zeit gewesen in dieser
bekämpfungsstrategie die anzahl der
menschen die erkrankten schwer erkranken
und sterben dass diese menschen diese
anzahl so klein wie möglich gehalten
wird und nach den modellierungen die die
stiko durchgeführt hat ist der effekt am
größten wenn die über 80 jährigen zuerst
geimpft wird
daraus erklärt sich das ganz einfach
ihre frage zu den schulen die schulen ja
die schulen sind ein ort an dem
natürlich infektion stattfinden habe ich
auch letzte woche wieder berichtet wir
haben wenn ich das richtig im kopf bis
heute rund 719 ausbrüche in den schulen
offiziell gemeldet natürlich finden in
schulen infektionen stadt das ist ja der
grund warum wir empfehlen dass in allen
schulen massen getragen wird und dass
wir empfehlen je nachdem wie hoch die
inzidenz ist auch die maßnahmen in den
schulen noch verschärft wird
aber die schulen sind nach den
informationen die wir haben und diese
tabelle diese inzidenz grafik die frau
die eben gezeigt wird die auch in
unserem lager bricht ist die zeit auch
sehr schön die inzidenz in den
bestimmten altersgruppen das sind nicht
die gruppen mit den höchsten instanzen
aber selbstverständlich finden dort auch
infektionen statt und werden dort auch
infektionen hineingetragen
insofern und das sind ja die einzigen
orte wo wir momentan noch viele menschen
auf einem engen raum zusammen bringen
den klassenräumen
insofern würden wir natürlich möglichst
viele maßnahmen als wirksam ansehen die
dazu beitragen dass die inzidenz
insgesamt in deutschland reduziert wird
und dann
sind die schulen natürlich auch ein teil
des infektions geschehens das sehen wir
das ist so und das können wir das sind
fakten die wir wahrnehmen müssen wir
gehen zum focus herr meier bitte auf die
verheerende situation in
altenpflegeheimen die zahl der toten ist
doppelt so hoch wie im sport sei
jetzt möchte sie gerne fragen woran
liegt das
sehen sie versäumnisse seit dem frühjahr
bezug auf den schutz bewohnern von
pflegeheimen und es maßnahmen die sie
jetzt recht kurzfristig der politik
empfehlen würden um die ist situation
doch noch zu verbessern
wir haben ja empfehlungen ich weiß nicht
wann wir das erste mal empfehlung dazu
gemacht haben sie schon ein paar monate
her
wir haben gerade ja die empfehlung noch
einmal überarbeitet auch zusammen mit
dem pflege beauftragten was eben
einzelnen die gründe sind das wissen wir
natürlich nicht immer aber nicht nennen
nur einen umstand den wir natürlich auch
immer im kopf haben müssen es gibt ja
zum beispiel auch an einen relevanten
anteil an etwa von dementen bewohnern in
solchen alten und pflegeheim und ist
natürlich sehr sehr schwer oder
beziehungsweise gar nicht möglich dass
sich die entsprechend verhalten
und es gibt eine reihe von gründen warum
in den alten und pflegeheimes auch
besonders schwierig ist und unabhängig
davon was jetzt genau in den einzelnen
pflegeheim wie ein virus hineingetragen
wird und wie sich dann verbreitet es ist
eben doch einfach eine extrem wohlrabe
gruppe und das heißt also auch wenn dort
sagen wir kleine ausbrüche sind
kleine wie sie auch im krankenhaus
auftreten dann ist einfach die gruppe
die von diesem virus daneben infiziert
wird so sowohl rabl so anfällig dass
dort einfach die die die sterberaten
sehr sehr hoch sind das ist einfach auch
dem ambiente zu geschuldet die menschen
sind eben besonders leicht schwer
infizierte leicht erkranken besonders
schwer und sterben eben deutlich höher
es gibt eine neue arbeit die ist in
dieser woche publiziert worden von levin
in der us amerikanische arbeitsgruppe in
der das sterberisiko mal oder didi didi
die sterberaten wirklich berechnet
wurden und sie sehen dass die
mitzunehmen alter kontinuierlichen
linear steigt und wir haben bei den über
80-jährigen sterberaten die liegen bei
weit über 15 20 prozent das ist der
umstand den wir einfach wahrnehmen
müssen ja vielleicht kann ich noch eine
sache ergänzt sie hat sagten doppelt so
viele verstorbene ich meine doppelte
fast doppelt so viele ausbrüche also die
anzahl der verstorbenen und den anteil
den hatte ich jetzt nicht ausgerechnet
mit gebracht ist aber auf jeden fall
auch sehr relevant keine frage wir
hatten letzte woche gezeigt
auch in der abbildung dass in den
krankenhäusern das sehr viel besser
gelungen ist die ausbrüche zu verhindern
als jetzt in den alten und pflegeheimen
und das zeigt schon dass es möglich ist
dass ist in alten und pflegeheimen aber
schwieriger ist ich möchte schon sagen
dass ich denke dass auch sehr viel
verhindert wird also was wir ja sehen
das sind diejenigen fälle wo es nicht
geklappt hat diejenige ausbrüche wo es
nicht geklappt hat
wir sehen nicht wo es überall verhindert
werden konnte und es sind durchaus noch
wesentlich dramatischere szenarien
vorstellbar aber diesen virus aber
dennoch ist es zu viel auf jeden fall
und ein ganz relevanter punkt ist
natürlich der personalmangel
in den alten und pflegeheimen der dass
den mitarbeitern extrem erschwert kommt
ja hinzu wenn sie den ausbruch haben das
dann auch viele selbst vielleicht
betroffen sind quarantäne gehen das wird
dann also sehr verschärft in diesen
einrichtungen und dann kann es auch sehr
schnell zu kritischen situationen kommen
dass die versorgung der bewohner
betrifft und das erklärt möglicherweise
auch zum teil die sehr sehr sehr hohen
anzahl an betroffenen dann jeweils
vielen dank wir gehen zum ende wie der
höckel ich habe eine frage zu den anti
gegen schnelltests hersteller gegen die
sensitivität sehr hoch an so in der
regel mit 98 prozent getestet und
verglichen mit pc oben kam zu dem
ergebnis dass die sensitivität nur bei
60 prozent liegt verlassen da bei 30
prozent
jeder zweite infizierte demnach nicht
erkannt von diesen tests wie bewerten
sie dieses ergebnis vor dem hintergrund
dass ich so schnell
es ist geradezu eine sehr stark beworben
werden erkenntnisse wie stark wie sehr
diese schnelltests begleitet sind so das
ist eine sehr gute sehr wichtige frage
also zum einen ist es so dass wir ja
diese tests gemeinsam mit anderen
laboren auch validieren über die
nächsten wochen und monate und wir
erwarten natürlich auch von den
herstellern dass sie selber so genannte
post marketing studien durchführen und
sie müssten bestimmte qualitätsparameter
erreichen
das ist die grundlage dafür dass sie auf
der liste erscheinen die im b fahren
dann publiziert wurden von dieser liste
werden eben all diejenigen die dann
getestet werden und die qualität war
heute nicht erfüllen runtergenommen die
tatsache dass die spezifität und
sensitivität wie sie von den herstellern
genannt wird höher ist das ist erwartbar
gewesen und zwar ist das darauf
zurückzuführen dass die eben im labor
unter recht guten bedingungen testen ob
der test eben zum beispiel virus das in
zellkultur an gezüchtet wird positiv
erkennt oder nicht aber im reallife also
in der situation wo man proben nimmt aus
der nase oder aus dem rachen oder wo
auch immer dann je nachdem welche test
wie wie der test konfiguriert ist dann
gibt es natürlich störfaktoren und diese
störfaktoren die muss man raus rechnen
die muss man die sieht man es in studien
und das ist der grund warum das
robert-koch-institut wie gesagt auch
jetzt verlangen zwei drei monate ist das
schon dass wir da mit validierungen
durchführen und wir haben tests
sensitivität und spezifität von 80
prozent als limit genommen damit der
test dann noch eingesetzt werden kann
oder nicht
und das sind dann die realen daten und
das ist ja auch einer der gründe warum
wir bei einem positiven test verlangen
dass wir oder was empfehlen dass ein
positiver test auch mit meiner pc
überprüft wird
der zweite punkt in denen ich da
anschließen möchte und das ist auch noch
mal gut dass sie das sagen das ist auch
einer der gründe warum wir der ansicht
sind dass diese tests eben auch mit
verstand und von fachleuten eingesetzt
werden sollten und zwar im rahmen einer
bestimmten test strategie wie sie zum
beispiel in alten- und pflegeheim in
krankenhäusern oder vielleicht auch in
den anderen bereichen durchgeführt wird
es muss immer dabei beachtet werden wie
hoch etwa die prävalenz also die
häufigkeit des virus in der gruppe ist
die man da untersucht und daraus ergeben
sich nämlich dann sogenannte prädiktive
werte aus den man abschätzen kann wie
gut dieser test eigentlich war und dann
muss man entsprechend eine berechnung
durchführen das ist zum beispiel
durchgeführt worden auch mit den
antikörper tests die wir heute mit dem
irische butter veröffentlicht haben da
gibt's korrektur faktoren und das zeigt
eben einfach dass tests wirklich auch in
die hand von fachleuten gehören die
verstehen wie sie das auswerten können
wie sie das bewerten können und im laufe
der zeit da gehe ich aber davon aus wenn
die tests immer besser und dann wird die
verlässlichkeit auch immer höher und das
ist ein prozess den wir auch
kontinuierlich monitor und das der grund
warum manche dieser tests aus der liste
des bv mauch verschwinden werden auf
dauer vielleicht kommen auch noch neue
dazu
vielen dank noch der hinweis dass
nachfragende moment nicht möglich sind
weil wir sonst mit der zeit nicht
hinkommen wir gehen zur welt herr
wittmann und morgen ja sowieso wieder
sie haben davon gesprochen dass es
rekordzahlen gibt sie haben davon
gesprochen dass er auch gerade die
todeszahlen nachlaufender indikator sind
uns darauf einstellen dass in den tagen
einer woche zehn tagen vielleicht zwei
wochen noch mehr werden
jetzt machen wir uns mal ein szenario
aus indem millionen deutsche durch
deutschland reisen familien treffen und
dann gemeinsam am tisch sitzen oder
szenario heißt weihnachten
jetzt sind einige maßnahmen ja erst nach
weihnachten angekündigt die unzufrieden
sind sie da oder beziehungsweise mal
klassische gesagt wie sehr zart gesehen
da schneide auch den angstschweiß auf
die stirn wenn sie genau an die nächsten
zwei wochen denken auch mit dem punkt an
dem wir jetzt hin und wenn dann noch mal
was dazu bekennen also wir wissen dass
das kein hilfreiche szenario wäre und
wir fordern die mit menschen in unserem
land auf dieses szenario nicht
wirklichkeit werden zu lassen
sie haben genau recht wenn dies so wäre
dann gehen ich und auch wirklich fast
alle die sich sehr ernsthaft mit dieser
krankheit befassen davon aus dass die
zahlen nach oben gehen werden und wir
dann eben wirklich zu namen von fällen
hätten und zunamen auch von todesfällen
das ist der grund warum wir an die
menschen appellieren dass sie das eben
nicht tun es soll ein weihnachten werden
wo wir auch über wo wir natürlich
zusammen sein sollen wir wollten das
auch mal positiv sehen wir können uns ja
schützen von diesem virus wir können
zusammen seien viele von uns können dann
eben virtuell zusammen seien in dieser
zeit und es wird eben ein beschauliches
weihnachten wird es das bei mir zu hause
ein beschauliches weihnachten wo wir uns
auch besinnen über dieses jahr und
positiv in der nähe anschauen können
weil wir im nächsten jahr einen
impfstoff haben werden nach aller
voraussicht der uns im laufe des jahres
dann auch in einer menge zur verfügung
steht dass alle die willig sind geimpft
werden aber ich kann wirklich alle
mitmenschen nur bitten dass sie
weihnachten eben nicht reisen möglichst
nicht reisen wenn es irgendwie möglich
ist sondern die begegnung er im
virtuellen haben und auf kleine gruppen
beschränken sowie das in irgendeiner
weise möglich ist wir hatten nur ein
beispiel in den usa thanksgiving
auch dort haben alle die so sich darüber
gedanken machen inklusive dem chief
medical officer fauzy inklusive meines
kollegen robert redfield vom csd alle
haben vorausgesehen dass wenn
sechs gewinnen eine solche reisewelle
ist dass die zahlen steigen und das
sehen wir und das möchte ich in
deutschland nicht und das möchte auch
niemand in deutschland
wir gehen zum deutschen ärzteblatt herr
oder frau berheide frau der heitere
gewährte deutsches ärzteblatt vielen
dank ich hätte zwei fragen zum einen
sieht mal öffentlich in der dienstags
immer diese grafik wo sich die leute
anstecken sie schreiben da auch seit
monaten ein dass man nur ein sechstel
lang verfolgen kann
wie kann sich der in die datengrundlage
dafür jetzt weiter den kommenden monaten
auch noch mal ein bisschen verbessert
sodass man auch insgesamt stärker auf
die privaten haushalte sind oder eben
die pflegeheime die deutlich ansteigen
frage 2 da gibt es noch mal um die
schnelltest und die werden ja die
ergebnisse wenn ihr in der eu tagen
decoder vanek nicht erfasst sollte es da
nicht noch mal vielleicht eine ergänzung
geben dass man auch diese tests erfassen
kann damit eben noch mal ein bisschen
schneller in die wahner hinausgeht für
die jetzt also die erste frage ich kann
nur sagen solange die zahlen so hoch
bleiben wie sie jetzt sind werden wir
die basis dort nicht wesentlich
verbessern können also einfach weil die
gesundheitsämter eben nicht mehr
nachkommen aber wissen sie was das
entscheidende eigentlich ist an dieser
grafik aber 20 prozent von von von 20%
informationen zu erhalten ist immer noch
sehr sehr viel wert daraus lernen wie
immer noch sehr sehr viel aber vor allen
dingen zeigt die grafik ja dass man sich
eben überall anstecken kann ja es gibt
keinen ort wo es nicht möglich ist und
das ist doch das was wir immer versuchen
den menschen zu vermitteln
wir können uns überall anstecken im
privaten bereich im beruflichen bereich
draußen in geschäften im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr
es gibt keinen ort wo das nicht
geschehen kann darum müssen wir uns
überall also acht haben wie möglich
verhalten ist dass erst das zweite ist
momentan werden ja in der korona waren
die testen dadurch erfasst dass wir eben
sagen wir wollen positive tests dadurch
erfassen dass sie mit einer pcr test
auch nachgeprüft werden und diese pcs
werden der nach wie vor erfasst in der
korona war ansonsten denken wir
natürlich kontinuierlich darüber nach
wie die entwicklung mit der krone at
weiter geht es gibt jede woche gibt es
zwei termine an denen wir uns darüber
gedanken machen schauen wir mal wie sich
die krone aber noch weiterentwickeln
wird in den nächsten wochen und monaten
wir gehen so vom mißlbeck sagen sie
nochmal die redaktion bitte
nachrichtendienst priorisierung das
konzept dann gibt es ja sehr viel kritik
von ärztlicher seite aber nicht nur so
kritisierte hartmannbund zum beispiel
dass die niedergelassenen ärzte unter
ferner liefen erst vorgesehen seien in
dem priorisierung konzert und dann gibt
es die kritik dass keine tests auf
antikörper vor der impfung vorgesehen
sind und damit praktisch impfdosen
verschwendet werden könnten an menschen
die als immun sind
ja also zunächst einmal noch mal es ist
ja eine empfehlung der stiko und diese
empfehlung ist noch nicht final das
möchte ich noch mal sagen ich habe es
ausdrücklich betont kritik ist
willkommen und die stiko das sind ist
ein unabhängiges gremium die werden sich
diese kritik auch anhören und werden
darüber nachdenken und sich äußern ich
möchte aber noch mal folgendes sagen
im gegensatz zu manchen einzelmeinungen
die bestimmt ihre gründe haben warum
dies oder jenes zu kritisieren ist die
stiko arbeitet seit mai diesen jahres
an diesen empfehlungen und die stiko
arbeitet evidenzbasiert dh das ist das
und zwar auf einem hohen level von
evidenz das niedrigste level von evidenz
ist die sogenannte expertenmeinung da
sind also meinungen wo man aufgrund
seines wissens denkt dies oder jenes sei
das bessere oder das schlechtere und
eine hohe evidenz grad beruht auf aus
für auswertung von literatur daten sogar
reviews also wo viele daten ausgewertet
und zwar nur deutsche die aufgehende
qualität haben und daneben auf
modellierungen und ich möchte das noch
mal sehr deutlich sagen alle diese
menschen die da april gelistet sind
den möchten wir diesen stoff zur
verfügung stellt aber wir müssen uns der
tatsache stellen dass wir zunächst eine
geringere menge von impfstoff haben und
nur weil eine gruppierung auf rang 4
oder vielleicht auf acht dieser
priorisierung ist das beruht darauf
nochmal das für ein bestimmtes ziel
haben das ziel ist wir wollen dass so
wenig menschen wie möglich in
deutschland schwer erkranken und sterben
und da hat die stiko sich entschlossen
und aufgrund der modellierung sagt sie
dass dies der beste weg ist das zu tun
ihre frage zu den antikörper test
ich hatte eben auch das ist eine gute
frage der wichtige frage ich hatte ihnen
eben vermittelt dass wir in deutschland
sehr wenig menschen nach dem was wir
wissen sehr wenig menschen zu erweitern
und also auf jeden fall unter zehn
prozent der menschen hatten schon mal
eine infektion
wir wissen noch gar nicht und da können
sie auch diejenigen die an vorderster
front immunologische arbeiten über
logisch forschen fragen wir wissen noch
gar nicht wie lange die immunität gegen
diese virus nach einer infektion
überhaupt anhält es gibt bereits klare
daten dass zum beispiel neutralisierende
antikörper vier fünf sechs monaten bei
einem relevanten teil der mitmenschen
verschwinden
insofern ist die entscheidung eben nicht
die antikörper zu testen genau die
richtige denn wir haben klare priorität
regeln nach alter nach vorerkrankungen
nach grunderkrankung nachholen gruppen
und da ist es
aus meiner sicht absolut fachlich
inhaltlich nachvollziehbar dass die
stiko diese empfehlung so macht wir
haben jetzt noch drei oder vier anfragen
bitte auch nur eine frage und nicht
durch die hintertür immer zwei wir gehen
zu herrn kreutzfeldt von der taz
wassergräben gefragt und da nicht
beantwortet wurde nämlich sie inzwischen
einmal zahlen zur zahl der
durchgeführten tests haben und wenn
nicht warum man das eine tunika
prioritäten geht denn für mich muss ich
sagen die zeit im moment wahnsinn ich
trete hier war weil man nicht mehr weiß
wie viele tests tatsächlich durchgeführt
werden wir im letzten jahr gelernt dass
die positiv quote sehr wichtig ist und
das zu interpretieren wie hoch die
dunkelziffer ist und so weiter
das weiß man ja nicht wenn die ganzen
negativen schnellste ist nicht erfasst
werden die positiven durch den pc der
nacht heißt schon dass meine frage wann
werden wir endlich mal zahlen kriegen da
wird diese ganzen welt in dieser
verlässt licht interpretierbar sind ja
ich beantworten also sie haben völlig
recht
auch die negativen befunde und überhaupt
die anzahl der erhobenen test der
durchgeführten tests ist extrem relevant
zur einschätzung der situation und
deswegen machen wir befragungen abfragen
bei laboren wie viele tests haben sie
durchgeführt
für die pcr test veröffentlichen wir das
ja auch wir haben leider keine
rechtsgrundlage um das jetzt
systematisch in der über alle labore zu
erheben wie viele tests wirklich
durchgeführt worden sind pro
altersgruppe pro region das kleinteilig
wirklich repräsentativ flächendeckend zu
erfassen
dazu fehlt es leider aber wir haben
verschiedene systeme implementiert die
uns ein gefühl dafür vermitteln
wir haben auch die daten aus die
veröffentlichen wir auch im lagebericht
und und in einem extra wochenbericht da
sind allerdings auch die pcr tests drin
und was die anti gen test betrifft das
sind wir dran was möglich ist aber es
bedeutet eben leider dann auch auf
freiwilligkeit von teilnehmenden laboren
und es kommt ja noch hinzu dass außer
den laboren jetzt auch zunehmend an
anderen stellen auch die anti gen tests
durchgeführt werden also in
einrichtungen in schulen möglicherweise
und das ist natürlich dann noch mal eine
ganz andere erhebung wenn da so viele
beteiligt sind wir hoffen da aber auf
eine hohe freiwillige beteiligungs rate
beginnt zu frau satori vom bdr
ich würde gern business wird wenn über
eine verschärfung der maßnahmen
besprochen wird weil sie hält nach
wochen gezeigt hat das reich wichtig und
die dann aus raab zu reduzieren
immer von der zeit nach weihnachten bis
anfang januar ist das nicht zu spät also
wir haben noch gelernt dass hier früher
mal ein rad und so besser sie sagt ja
das auto derzeit ist sehr wackelig ist
es nicht endlich an der zeit jetzt jetzt
sofort den nächsten block daran zu
versterben also die maßnahmen
verschärfen denke die wichtige maßnahme
ist die das wirklich verhindert wird
dass die lockerungen über weihnachten
kommen das ist etwas was dem
infektionsgeschehen eine dynamik gebe
die aus unserer sicht schwer zu
kontrollieren ist
und das ist ein wichtiger aspekt dass
man das wirklich nicht tut und
unabhängig davon von den maßnahmen die
dann beschlossen werden
das sind ja politisch beschlossene
maßnahmen letztlich auf basis von
einzelnen bundesländern unabhängig davon
kann ich eben nur jeden mitbürger hier
in unserem land bitten dass er
unabhängig davon seine kontakte so weit
wie möglich einschränken
ich weiß dass das die mehrheit der
menschen tut ich weiß dass es viele gibt
die es aber tun wollen und und nicht
richtig machen manche haben ein paar
gedankensprünge wo sie eine situation
nicht richtig einschätzen und diejenigen
die es gar nicht tun und es gibt ja
sogar leugner dieser krankheit die die
kann ich auch die wird wahrscheinlich
auch niemand belehren können aber der
gute große mehrzahl der deutschen weiß
das und wir können auch unabhängig davon
ob maßnahmen verordnet werden und selber
in hohem maße schützen das ist der
appell den wir immer wieder haben wir
haben einen hohen bildungsstand wir sind
cleveres volk und wir haben das schon
mal geschafft wir wissen dass dass wir
das können und ich kann alle nur
ermutigen diesen weg zu gehen und das
schicksal selber in die hand zu nehmen
das können nicht alle in unserer
gesellschaft aber sehr sehr viele de gmx
herr oder frau huber mit der förderung
kurze fahren kurze antwort danke schön
herr professor bieler sie haben die
stellungnahme der leopoldina mit den
vormittag forderungen nach marken locker
und mit unterzeichnet ich habe mich
gefragt haben sie als leiter der
wichtigsten bundesbehörde in der korona
krise keine anderen
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten mit der
bundesregierung oder den
ministerpräsidenten
wo da kann man das so interpretieren
dass sie da einfach nicht zu den
entscheidern vorher durchgedrungen sind
ich habe andere kanäle und diese kanäle
werden auch genutzt und die
stellungnahme der leopoldina ist denke
ich ihn zusätzlich starkes signal denn
dort haben ja nicht nur biomediziner
unterzeichnet und epidemiologen und
virologen sondern eben auch fachleute
sehr angesehene wissenschaftler aus
anderen bereichen zum beispiel aus der
ökonomie noch zuhören reise in das ist
das die letzte frage hinzugekommene
können wir leider nicht mehr
berücksichtigen sind wirklich sehr
positiv er wird das mana positiv war von
fünf prozent der hoden oder höheren
dunkelziffer rechnen muss gerne von
einigen monaten und mehr gesehen wieder
sowie die sozusagen gibt es bei einigen
internen nachdem die rechnen oder
so setzen wir die dunkelziffer da kam
ich ergänzen wenn ich es vergesse also
wir haben in deutschland schon ein sehr
hohes niveau das dürfen sie einfach nie
vergessen das heißt wir testen sehr viel
von anfang an wir haben guten überblick
ich habe ihnen gerade auch gesagt dass
wir diese zero studien durchführen in
denen wir sehen dass die dunkelziffer in
den daten die wir bislang aus
deutschland kennen zwischen 4 und 6
liegen also vier bis sechs mal mehr sind
eventuell infiziert das sind nach wie
vor unter zehn prozent der bevölkerung
das heißt also dieser sie müssen sehen
dass die whu natürlich für die ganze
welt diese daten benennt und wir sind
sehr sehr zuversichtlich
die daten die uns zur verfügung stände
ganzen surveillance daten die wir ja
zusätzlich zu den reinen meldedaten
haben aus denen sich ja diese zahl der
positiven uhr gibt und aus den test
zahlen sind wir relativ sicher dass die
dunkelziffer nicht so hoch ist also bei
uns wir sind jetzt zurzeit glaube ich
habe wieder die 10 prozent positiven
raten überschritten
diese woche aufgrund der ganzen anderen
indikatoren die wir haben
denken wir nicht dass das was wir da ein
ganz falsches bild verlangt das war's
für heute und bleiben sie gesund
[Applaus]
[Musik]